never gossip about your man ever if
there's a texting with some other girl
you don't tell any of your girlfriends
you take it to a therapist you take it
to a 12-step meeting don't ever gossip
about your person don't ever make fun of
your person in public I see people a lot
women that don't understand why
relationships aren working and then you
go out on a double date and like cuz he
can't get and you're just like
what the are you doing you're
embarrassing your man in front of a
bunch of people I see this stuff and as
someone who's a female comic you would
think that that's not how I am in
relationships in the slightest and I
think that we're just getting a little
too comfortable